i'm afraid of taking five grams right
now
i don't i i think probably
well you know in hamlet he says i screw
my courage to the sticking point
this sounds obscene but he's actually
referring to fiddling with his uh
sword
and keeping it from falling too far into
his scabbard so that's what you have to
do you have to screw your courage to the
sticking point there is other there are
other things that you can do there is a
body of literature anthropological
there's pharmacological literature it's
very reassuring when you after you've
taken five grams to be able to recite to
yourself little mantras from the medical
literature about how harmless this is
about how it all goes away in eight
hours
and
it's also good to remind yourself that
you know you don't always get what you
want sometimes you get what you need
um
i don't know how you prepare for it you
yearn for it i guess i mean you want to
be with it it is not unfrightening
and i've always been at pains to point
that out to people
and to be very frank about it i mean i
admire the people who say it's always so
wonderful and the people who call it
silly sciben
but
you know
poke around long enough it is the main
thing that you can guarantee about these
things is they can always surprise you
and it's not always pleasant to be
surprised it takes a certain
mentality i mean i don't think this
stuff is for everybody and i i really
don't think it's for fragile people
it's a litmus
test for psychosis this is what gives it
this is what gives it a bad name because
people say you know this guy took it and
then he went completely bananas well
i really believe that
he was completely bananas before
but that his very delicately constructed
and maintained equilibrium was not
capable of mean of
surviving a full hit
of
this
strange
transcendent truth that is revealed
basically what it is is it destroys your
preconceptions
whatever they were it stands you on your
head it shows you that no matter how
smart you are no matter how much you
think you know about what's going on
you're dead wrong
it does that to me all the time i mean
when i'm
the last time i did it there were points
in it where i had to say to myself
they don't have to make this stuff
illegal hell it is illegal
you know it's intrinsically illegal it's
violating the laws of physics for one
thing
um
but it's a
it's a wonderful
it's the cure for boredom is what it is
it raises the stakes on that i mean i
don't think you can cure boredom without
taking some risks really cure it but it
says you know you don't have to accept a
small definition of yourself or the
world you are not locked in
there are
doorways into unexpected dimensions that
no one can close away from you if you
but have the courage to walk through
them
and a funny thing about courage
is that
nature loves it
all advance has occurred through acts of
courage nature loves courage
and the way she responds to it is by
removing obstacles
this is how the shaman is able to do the
impossible dance above the waterfall he
literally
rushes in where angels fear to tread
and is then able to dance like an angel
because nature says
you know faced with an act of faith like
that am i going to let this guy plunge
300 feet to splat
i don't think so
you